so I guess just to start off I mean
shooting in Chicago do you have time to
sort of explore the city and find places
I did will take but with several places
do you do you find her or go to
restaurants too many what's the best
restaurant for hamburgers I don't even
eat hamburgers what's the best
restaurant for chicken what's the best
restaurant for barbecue I explored so
many restaurants and so many mixed
drinks later I love this city and I was
here with my eight-year-old daughter so
the parks fantastic parts here you know
just one of my favorite cities what are
the best restaurants in Chicago just
theoretically I love the river Rose I
have to say they it's just awesome what
about for you Liam what are your
favorite ice ed it I did a movie here
over 30 years ago with God rest him my
Patrick Swayze unbuild Paxton and we
were brothers I remember driving a
motorbike that I did not have a license
or potty
Patrick taught me how to ride and go
into Kingston mines and hearing blues
for the first time hmm that was quite
extraordinary so he did that most nights
we were shooting a hillbilly movie here
you know did you did you go back to
these places shooting this movie or I
did yeah I didn't really have time to be
honest with you you know but I certainly
noticed a lot of changes you know I mean
it's just when you get a script for
something like widows does your
character of script change at all when
you sort of decide to join the project
no I don't think this changed too much
certainly not but Gillian and Steve had
written what tends to be the first thing
you do when you get a script to sort of
find the character for yourselves for me
I keep reading the script I'm one of
those I'm I I work really slow so you
have to read the script over and over
and over
again because if your character is
described as I don't know I'm gonna just
throw something out there as being
overweight eats a lot and then goes to
sleep at six o'clock every night then
guess what that's who you are
and so that's why you have to read the
script over and over again and get all
the stats on your character and then you
and then after that you have to do all
the work of creating a person but you
have to I have to keep reading the
script is there something you learn in
particular after rereading you know 110
times 10 50 times absolutely there's
always a discovery it's sort of like
it's sort of like being in a
relationship that sometimes it's like it
takes you in 15 18 years and realized
that's right he did tell me that when I
first met him I just chose not to hear
it well I agree with iolite you know you
reading you rereading you reread you
know but the first time I this was a few
years ago someone told me it was
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] my part to
get over that
[Laughter]
you